There's nothing like having to enjoy dessert
that's filled with corn syrup
and way too much refined sugars.
I don't know about you,
but I like to enjoy dessert that makes me feel good afterwards,
adding to my vitality
rather than potential diabetes or chronic disease.
This pecan pie. I'm starting out by making buttery crust from scratch
using glyphosate free, regeneratively grown primitive wheat.
I'm killing two birds with one stone by making double crust.
After chilling the dough for one hour,
I roll it out on a flowered surface,
rotating each time to avoid sticking.
Although I was meticulous,
I rolled it out too thin. This crust was a shame,
so I stuck it back in the fridge and used my second crust,
which went quite well on round two.
Using my rolling pin, I unrolled the crust onto my pie dish,
then crimped the edges using my thumb,
and placed the crust pressed into the freezer for one hour.
During this time, I chopped the pecans for the filling
and made my syrup of browned butter,
maple syrup, and cream.
Next, I created the remaining filling of coconut and maple sugars,
pasture raised eggs, vanilla,
and salt. I carefully drizzled in the hot syrup
while whisking constantly to avoid curdling the eggs.
I added my chopped pecans to my frozen pie crust,
poured the filling over top,
and decorated with pecan halves before baking.
After cooling overnight,
we cut into this delicious pecan pie with nourishing ingredients.
This crust was flaky and buttery,
and the filling was crunchy and slightly chewy.